joining us now is I'm Sheldon Thomas
he's a former gang member who no longer
consultancy firm that trained
professionals to understand gang
mentality and Sheldon thanks so much and
for joining us this morning and what we
were hearing there one officer
describing describing the situations
people habitually carrying knives one
officer from the elite gang unit saying
that actually stop and search does work
for from your experience now and indeed
previously as a gang member do you think
stop and search or work is this the way
of tackling knife crime I think I think
there's a history of stop and search
which has a negative impact on
particular communities especially in the
black Kemeny and I don't think there is
any evidence to prove that stocking
search actually reduces knife crime in
my days it actually had a reverse effect
and actually caused many of us to resent
the police in the way they in put arm
kind of delivered that you know stop and
search process for me the biggest
problem is that we're tackling this on
an enforcement and you can't rock your
way and enforce your way out of this
situation it's a culture and once we
understand it's a culture and they
operate these young people who live this
laughter and remember many of these
young people who carried knives are not
even in gangs what they're doing is
they're carrying a knife because of the
fear of the gangs because they live in
neighborhoods where most of them don't
have any father figures there's no
positive male role models in their life
they live in estates where mass
unemployment is they live where mums are
struggling maybe with two or three other
younger kids so it's kind of easier just
to let me hold the one go out we saw in
the report there and you know sport
quite often does provide outlets and
help for for people and the boxing in
that report but is enough being done and
what more can be done do you think to
try and include those let's be honest
mainly young men who feel that they
don't have a stake in the society that
they live in and therefore the violence
doesn't have a consequence because
there's nothing to lose well to answer
that question society has to look at
itself because if we're not going to tap
is on a social front because this is
where the problem is it's a social and a
mental issue you can't tackle social
problems with enforcement so I think
where you're talking about how those
young people who feel left out in
society feel a part of society Society
the government has to look at what are
they doing to make every young person
inclusive in society because at the
moment there is a disparity among
especially young kids unemployed
apprenticeships don't really offer a
real solution because the pay is so
ridiculously low so when you look at a
gang member
it becomes attractive to a young person
because if you look at apprenticeships
and what they're offering there's no
guarantee of a job in fact most
apprenticeships don't offer a job at the
end of it the young person is thinking
well I might as well go down this road
and this is if the gang members they're
making that they show it they're
enticing them with living a good life
it's the only way potentially they could
make money in the environment that
they're growing up in so is it about
tackling those gang members which
essentially to stop and search it could
do that could take could I'm in prison
and gang members and take them out of be
the state south of out of these areas in
London yes you can yes the police can do
that there's a place for a role for the
police
but this is a bigger picture than the
police this is actually a social problem
because we're not addressing it from
that world remember very in a different
world to us in their world they get up
when there was they do what they want
they tackle their issues how they feel -
in our world we have a process a way of
doing things so we need to understand
the world they're in is separate to our
world and if we're going to tackle we
have to understand their world and
because we don't understand their world
it's where people like us come in to try
and train professionals to understand
the world by which these young people is
because if you're not included in
society you're going to go to where you
feel included or sense of belonging and
unfortunately the attraction of gangs
through the music they put on some of
them promote becomes a way of life
and unfortunately carrying a knife isn't
just about the fear factor it's now a
culture okay then sad it doesn't look
like from what you're saying stop and
search will be enough to tackle
issue hope you'll find out in time and
Sheldon Thomas really good talking to
you thank you